this is why I didn't do this to her when
you were with her because I knew it'd
make her feel uncomfortable I feel that
you're not saying something see week 2
was bumpy for some couples in paradise
as Jordan and Mike showed up but the
Hannah G Blake and Dylan love triangle
took the cake she's a freaking player
just like Blake Blake swooped in to
steal Hannah G right at the end of
Monday's episode I think paradise is
incredibly successful you know this is a
lot of couples that come out of that
leaving Dylan with a lot of questions do
they gave before this or something of
course we can always count on Jordan to
cut the tension with some humor and
there's a such thing as just being a
dumbass and Blake yeah he's a dumbass
right now et spoke with host Chris
Harrison about the drama bubbling up in
paradise and how things man for Blake so
how bad do things get for him is there
any redemption for Blake well I mean
things get about as bad as they can yeah
then Hannah starts making out with Blake
and you know even Demi was like what are
you doing he's a loser what do you think
she was doing I don't know but I guess
is the beauty of the show is that it's
still like the fact that the lake
thought this has been the worst three
days of my life I have been outed in the
worst possible way I'm not gonna leave
I'm gonna triple down I'm going to after
making out what tisha let me go for
Hannah
so do things end happily for Blake I'll
see how it could right I mean is it
possible maybe it's paradise okay I
don't see how they could and don't know
to Blake no music festivals this year
but
you
[Applause]